hello hello everyone from W to
headquarters here in Geneva welcome to
regular press briefing on kovat 19
today is June 17 2020 today with us we
have doctors as always W
director-general and as we usually do
with us we have dr. Mario Van Kirk Kove
who is technical lead for coffee 19 dr.
Mike Ryan who is the head of emergency
programs and we have a free other guests
today from WTO we have dr. Maulana
lechera
who is a WTO director for neglected
tropical diseases we have dr. janet diaz
who is the head of clinical care at
coded 19 response and we also have dr.
ana-maria hanna Restrepo with the head
of the research and development unit and
working on a blueprint at wh show I will
remind you analysts who are watching us
on zoom' that you can listen this press
briefing in 16 languages plus Portuguese
Plus Hindi if you do that through your
settings on zoom you can also ask your
questions in 16 languages and Portuguese
today our press conference will be a
little bit shorter than usual we have to
finish by 6 o clock
Geneva time so we will try to be concise
in answering and also asking questions
now I will give a floor to dr. terrors
thank you thank you Tarek good morning
good afternoon and good evening the
world has now recorded more than 8
million cases of kovat 19 in the past
first two months 85,000 cases were
reported but in the past two months six
million cases have been reported there
have been more than four hundred
thirty-five thousand deaths in the
Americas Africa and South Asia cases are
still rapidly rising however there are
green shoots of hope
which show that together through global
solidarity humanity can overcome this
pandemic we now have examples of many
countries good examples that have shown
how to effectively suppress the virus
with a combination of testing tracing
and quarantining patients and caring for
those that get sick lab capacity has
been dramatically enhanced across the
world to boost copied 19:00 testing
which is critical for identifying where
the virus is and informing government
actions new mega hubs have been
established that are now key to the
distribution of personal protective
equipment which includes millions of
masks goggles aprons and gloves as well
as other medical supplies tech companies
have developed applications that can
assist with the critical task of contact
tracing and there has been an enormous
effort to accelerate the science around
the pandemic early on in the outbreak on
11th February whu-oh convened a research
and innovation forum on kovat 19 where
hundreds of researchers came together
from across the world with the aim of
quickly developing quality Diagnostics
therapeutics and vaccines one of the key
priorities identified was for the world
to focus on accelerating research around
treating patients with copied 19
specifically researchers agreed to
investigate existing drugs with
potential including steroids
WHU also developed a core protocol which
has been adapted and used by researchers
around the world and yesterday there was
the welcome news of positive initial
results from the recovery trial in the
United Kingdom dexamethasone a common
steroid has been shown to have a
beneficial effect on those patients
severely ill with Kabat 19 according to
early findings shared with WH er for
patients on oxygen
along the treatment was shown to reduce
mortality by about one-fifth and for
patients requiring a ventilator
mortality was reduced by about one-third
however dexamethasone was shown to not
have a beneficial effect for those with
milder disease who did not need
respiratory support this is very welcome
news for those patients with severe
illness this drug should only be used
under close clinical supervision
we need more therapeutics that can be
used to tackle the virus including those
with milder symptoms wgo has now started
to coordinate a meta-analysis pulling
data from several clinical trials to
increase our overall understanding of
this intervention and we will update our
clinical guidance to reflect how and
when dexamethasone should be used to
treat covett 19 I want to thank the
United Kingdom government the University
of Oxford and the many hospitals
researchers patients and families who
have contributed to the scientific
breakthrough de Blasio will continue to
work with all partners to develop other
therapeutics and vaccines for Kabat 19
including through the access to copied
19 tools accelerator over the coming
weeks and months we hope there will be
more treatments that improve patient
outcomes and save lives while we're
searching for copied 19 treatments we
must continue strong efforts to prevent
as many infections as possible by
finding isolating testing and caring for
every case and tracing and quarantining
every contact kovat 19 is affecting the
whole world but it's important to
remember that for the most vulnerable
communities this is just one of many
threats they face we have consistently
stressed the importance of ensuring
essential service to country continue
including routine vaccinations and
services for malaria TB and HIV today I
want to touch on neglected tropical
diseases an issue I care deeply about
entities are a group of twenty days
including
elephantiasis sleeping sickness leprosy
trachoma and intestinal worms that
collectively wreak havoc on the poorest
and most marginalized communities this
diseases disfigure disabled and can kill
and they strike hardest in place faces
of poverty and in remote areas where
access to quality health services is
extremely limited whu-oh and partners
have developed a new roadmap which moves
away from single disease programs to
integrated approaches to the prevention
diagnosis and treatment of neglected
tropical disease as part of an overall
movement toward eat or timber cell
health coverage the entity roadmap puts
greater ownership on national and local
governments to drive action like with
kovat 19 it calls for greater
collaboration between governments
academia civil society and the private
sector in order to boost innovation and
access to health technologies I have
seen firsthand the courage of people who
are living with entities which is why I
call on countries not to forget about
the most vulnerable together we can
achieve anything and I'm encouraged by
progress in tackling the Ebola outbreak
in the east of the Democratic Republic
of Congo if there are no more cases in
the next seven days the government of
DRC will be able to declare the outbreak
over the lessons learned and experience
gained by Congolese health workers are
now being applied to inform the Ebola
outbreak response in the West of the DRC
as well as broader
on testing and contact tracing which are
directly transferable for tackling covet
19 I thank you many thanks dr. Tetris
and just to remind you that we have our
director for neglected tropical diseases
here dr. La Jolla who can talk more
about the roadmap that dr. Tigers just
mentioned we will start with the
questions please be concise and one
question per person we will start with
FA news agency and we have Antonio broto
Antonio can you amuse and see me
pregunta es sobre la dexamethasone a--
desde la même SI usted esté LeBron este
lado de la universidad de ox4 Mero
debería la población general a - are con
call tell a respecter con su mo desde
medica mento pora hemp low a low or 'day
daya sur l'eau de forma prevent eva
muchos Gracias yes absolutely and very
very bad you asked this question and
Jonathan Ana Maria may wish to
supplement it's exceptionally important
that this drug is used under medical
supervision this is not for mild cases
this is not for prophylaxis this is a
very very powerful anti-inflammatory
drug it can rescue patients who are in
very serious condition where their lungs
and their cardiovascular system around
their lungs may be very inflamed so this
allows possibly the patients are able to
continue getting oxygen into the blood
from the lungs for a very critical
period by rapidly reducing inflammation
at a critical period in their illness it
is not a treatment for the virus itself
it is not a prevention for the virus in
fact steroids and particularly powerful
steroids can be associated with viral
replication in other words they can
actually facilitate the the
the the division and replication of
viruses and human bodies so it's
exceptionally important in this case
that this drug is reserved for use in
severely ill and critical patients who
can benefit from the stroke clearly and
as the director-general said this is
great news but it is part of the answer
we need on the clinical site oxygen
ventilation the use of antivirals the
use of steroids and finding a
combination of therapies that allows us
to save as many patients as possible
Janet thank you so now I just have to
echo the the benefit was seen in
patients who are on oxygen therapy so
who had already lung injury or those
patients that were on ventilation so
there was no benefit seen in the
patients that had mild disease so this
is the in this study was not for
prophylaxis so I think the that is the
take-home message as you've described
Mike many thanks so next question will
go to Jason from NPR Jason Bob young
Jason can you just press unmute please
Jason can you press unmute so we get we
get to you sorry can you hear me now no
it's fine I was just wondering if you
could just talk any more about the
continued work with the United States in
terms of ongoing programs what what are
things most things continuing to go
forward in terms of work with United
States so I could start and then and
then others might want to supplement I
can speak to the work that we do with
the United States for kovat 19 and other
programs so yes of course you know we
work with scientists all over the world
including American scientists and public
health professionals and medic
professionals mainly in our day-to-day
work through collaborative international
networks so we have established
international networks of experts for
clinical management for vaccine
development and therapeutics for
mathematical modeling for infection
prevention and control for risk
communication for many different areas
of work and those include scientists
from from the United States from US CDC
from NIH and many academic groups and so
that will continue we also work of
course with with scientists from many
countries all over the world and I think
that's one of the the strengths that we
have as an organization to bring people
together to share first-hand experience
firsthand practical experience with
patients in health facilities in
communities to be able to exchange and
we will continue to learn from one
another
fully agree with with Maria and are
collaborating and beyond Escobedo we
have many many collaborating centers all
over the United States hugely important
contributions that they individually and
collectively make to global health and
and I think the the the issue here is
that these institutions and individuals
are contributing to global health we all
work on global health together we all
work together to ensure that we improve
the health experience the health
outcomes and the survival of all people
on this planet and we really do
recognize and thank the power of US
scientists and US scientists and public
health professionals in fact today we
have Maria from the east coast of the
United States Janet from the west coast
of the United States and and the
Americas is equally further represented
by Anna Maria Hanna from the country of
Colombia so the most represented group
at this table right now is the Americas
and the United States of America from
the perspective of how US citizens
around the world contribute not only to
the health and welfare of Americans but
to the health and welfare of the world
give them instructor Diaz and dr. Ryan
and Maria so we will go to Yahoo Finance
and we have anjali online and jolly
hello can you unmute yourself and jolly
if possible if it's not working we will
try to go to
Siddhant Montana from India TV
Siddhant can you hear us hello yes
please
yeah so my question is also about the
dexamethasone drug trials I have there
been any talks of initiating the trials
on a much wider scale and would you say
that this drug would stand I mean I mean
it the drug could be used as a drug that
is both feasible inefficiently providing
it to patients all across the world and
also effective against coronavirus thank
you let me just restate that this drug
we have first of all with great
congratulations to my colleague Peter
Harvey and and and all of the great
researchers in the UK and as director
general said to the doctors the nurses
the patients their families have
participated in this it is one but of
the many breakthroughs were going to
need in order to effectively deal with
covert 19and and as such we should
celebrate that today but it's still just
preliminary data it's from one study
it's very significant but we also have
to see the real data the full data and
we thank our colleagues in the UK for
briefing us but we still obviously and
they will be working very hard over the
coming days to released detailed data to
get this published in peer-reviewed
journals so everybody can see what the
the results are from that at the same
time Janet and her team will be doing
some work on more systematic reviews
around other data that may be available
around the world and on that basis we
will pull together the necessary expert
group to look at all of that both
research in the clinical site and come
to a conclusion around our clinical
advice to countries and it's important
that each country takes that's a
measured approach as well this is not
the time to rush to change clinical
practice in a in a in a in a to rush to
fashion people need training we need to
understand what doses to be used how
patients are going to be clinically
assessed we need to make sure there are
supplies of the drug we need to look at
a lot of a lot of things so while we're
very pleased today we still need to see
the final data we need to adjust the
clinical guidelines that will be needed
and we need to support countries to both
access and utilize this drug in the most
appropriate way possible and let me say
it again it cannot be said strongly
enough this drug is purely for use under
close clinical supervision it is meant
and has only been shown so far to be
useful in the treatment of severely ill
people with covert 19:00 those people
are L'Occitane those people who are
ventilators and while we're very pleased
to see a life-saving intervention emerge
please please let us use it and take
forward the use of this drug for what it
has shown to be beneficial in doing
genis there we go just to echo that is
really important to see the full data
the full report from the manuscript in a
peer-reviewed journal so we look forward
to that
currently we know there are other
ongoing randomized control trials
testing steroids for kovat 19:00 and we
are assembling and coordinating to
aggregate data from those trials in a
meta-analysis to to give us a bigger
perspective a wider perspective of the
studies that are ongoing and then at the
same time putting into place the
mechanisms in order to update our
guidance in a transparent and
trustworthy way with global experts
representing all regions of the world in
a in the very near future so all that's
going on in place and again just
echo this is something that should be
used in hospital for severe patients for
those that are critically ill but not
for mild patients and we hope in the
very near future to have more you know
our recommendations more clear the
practice protocols adjusted accordingly
and other tools to assist frontline
clinicians and member states to make the
appropriate adjustments to their
national guidelines
many thanks the next question comes from
CCTV we have shane with us Shane Shane
just a second
go ahead please yeah and hear me yes no
it's fine
okay Thank You Derek question to talk
potatoz potatoz you have attended the
extraordinary China Africa summit on
solidarity as hobby' 19 today and what
do you think about the meaning of this
summit and what do you think about
China's support to the African countries
in the fight against Kobe 19 thank you
yeah thank you
so the China Africa summit Pocock is one
of the platforms where China and Africa
partner and during this kovat situation
a special session was organized by China
South Africa and Senegal the three
leaders have co-hosted this meeting and
with a specific agenda of fighting covet
together so as you know since the
pandemic started China has been
supporting Africa and many countries
have already outlined the kind of
support they have been getting
especially in sending experts in sharing
information in addition to that in
providing supporting with supplies
hanging solidarity across the globe and
this should really be followed by global
solidarity to help speed up the defeat
of this virus so I'd like to use this
opportunity to call on unity and
solidarity of the whole world in my
speech I said I compared actually in the
first two months it was 85 thousand
cases and more than 90 percent of them
by the way with where in China but if
you take the last two months this is
from April mid-april up to now mid June
in just two months
six million cases from this you can see
how the virus is accelerating and moving
moving really fast we can move faster
because it's only by moving faster than
we can defeat it and to move faster the
most important element is unity and
solidarity which is political and that's
what we should really strengthen
national unity and global solidarity
thank you the next question is coming
from New York Times we have David wall
Stein with us David if you unmute
yourself we will hear you on Monday dr.
Ryan you mentioned you might have some
kind of a decision on Hydrox coracle
venue on that don't you never promised
us with doesn't deliver yes we've been
in we've been discussing with and again
because of the independent nature of the
Solidarity try
the fact that it has its own executive
committee in its own data safety
monitoring board we've been discussing
with the executive group that oversees
the trial the process now for for
looking at the data they Anna Maria can
confirm but the the executive committee
now and the dsm-v are looking at the
data across a number of yeah and she
will just outline the the process for
that but as of as of today we are
awaiting the the decision and analysis
of the of the steering committee for the
group and the analysis of the DSMB
Maria Anna Maria yes thank you Mike so
as Mike reported and digit reported a
few weeks ago we took three actions the
Fed action was to conduct the systematic
review of the evidence that was
conducted by the Cochrane Collaboration
one of our collaborators the second as
we look into the safety of
hydroxychloroquine among the patients
vaccinated vaccinated who were treated
in the Solidarity trial and in the
discovery trial in France
our sister companion trial and the
servicing that we promised is that we
will look into the evidence through our
data safety monitoring committee after
completing these three steps we have a
communication with our executive group
that is formed by the representatives of
seven of the member states who are
participating in the trial and today
just five minutes ago
we finalized a call with all the
investigators in the trial on the basis
of the evidence is available to the
investigators to the Secretariat to the
executive group and to the DSM C a
decision was made to stop the
randomization with a hydroxychloroquine
trial on the basis of two pieces of
information the first the data that was
published by the UK trial and second the
data that was available to us from the
Solidarity trial I will stop here
thank you doctor I know who is just to
remind everyone the head of our research
and development blueprint unit WH oh I
understand that we have a question on on
entities and it looked tropical diseases
our friend Simon a table is online and
would like to ask that yeah thank you
for taking my question my name is Simon
Akiba from today news Africa and
Washington DC and I would like the
expert I'm sorry I couldn't I can't see
the name very well from where yeah I
would like the African expect on the
panel to tell us how tell us about all
those neglected diseases in Africa and
how Kovach 19 is affecting them thank
you thank you very much for that
question it's without a doubt that
covered 19 has wreaked havoc in the
world and one of the places one of the
things that has been since severely
affected is our neglected tropical
disease programs worldwide and
particularly particularly in Africa
we've had - as part of the focus on
social distancing we've had to stop most
of the mass Drug Administration programs
in in in Africa and so the idea is now
to think about when when we go back post
covered how are we going to do our
programs what is the way that we're
going to do our programs better are
there innovative ways that we can
actually carry out these programs where
people can be treated safely and not
necessarily through mass drug
administration but making sure the
safety of the people being treated and
the safety of the community health
workers who are treating them so that is
the that is the discussion that is
ongoing but we have still as whu-oh
issued guidance that all programs that
involve any kind of mass Drug
Administration should be should be
halted and as a follow-up to that there
are diseases which require treatment
immediate treatment disease like
leishmaniasis which are also part
of the a neglected tropical disease
group and those diseases people are
still required to go to - to health
facilities and get their the requisite
treatment thank you many thanks to
Monticello so for Simon if you can't see
it but we will send you its dr. Wollan
allah tala director of whu-oh program
for neglected tropical diseases we will
go now to global Brazil Bianca - hi
Terry can you hear me yes very well
thanks a lot
my question is to dr. Mike Ryan how do
you see the situation in Brazil now do
you think the number of deaths has
stabilised do you see any sign of
stabilization and if so what does it
mean exactly what signs it can give us
Thanks
is this not working it's working okay
yeah I think the the epidemic is still
quite severe in believe workers are as
we said before working extremely hard
and under under pressure to be able to
deal with the number of cases that they
see on a daily basis
but certainly the the rise is not as
exponential as it was previously so
there are some signs that the situation
is stabilizing but we've seen this
before and other epidemics and other
countries you can see a sign of
stabilization for a day or a few days
and then it can the disease can take off
again so what I would say is it's a
moment of extreme caution in in Brazil
there needs to be a focus on physical
distancing on hygiene on reduced
crowding and and being able to support
populations particularly populations
from ethnic ethnic minorities for people
living in difficult conditions and urban
environments and poor conditions it's
difficult for people to do social
distancing it's difficult for people to
maintain personal hygiene and we have to
try and support them in in that so it is
I think from the perspective of Brazil a
moment now to really double down to
really focus on the public health and
social measures to focus on supporting
communities who find this both difficult
to sustain that and also have a greater
impact in terms of health to ensure that
the hospital system continues to
function and is able to cope with
severely ill patients if all of that is
done then we would expect Brazil has a
historically as I've said previously a
proud history of containing and
suppressing infectious diseases and I
have no doubt that if the full-scale
commitment ingenuity of the Brazilian
state of the of the provinces of the
people is leveraged in a United
sustained and combined way that Brazil
will bring this disease under control
and will succeed in emerging from this
as quickly as possible thank you doctor
our next question is from Mexico we have
Polina
Medina from Cancun Polina if you'll meet
yourself we will hear you
hola theme escuchan see channels gracias
a todos gracias Tarek kissy la pregunta
less in Cancun in general in Quinta
narrow entrance n temporada ya dengue
chikungunya pueden estos Intimus my
metas are say yo a grab our second
Covey's que Ventana tenemos para
diferencia are los que es la
recomendation que NOS pueden dar
oh I can start and then and then others
can supplement so that that's a very
good question and it highlights the the
need to ensure that we have surveillance
systems in place for not only covert 19
but for other pathogens that are
circulating and in in fact you know this
morning I had a call with teams across n
TD and my own team looking at
arboviruses and looking at dengue and
yellow fever and chikungunya and Zika
and how do we accelerate the arbovirus
work across the globe in kovat 19 how do
we ensure that countries are continuing
to fight against other pathogens that
exist that that that are common in many
parts of the world so that not only can
we detect cases but then we can
distinguish between who is infected with
which pathogens how does this affect the
clinical pathway in terms of what
patients need in terms of clinical care
and how we can protect onward
transmission within families within
communities and so this is this is
something that is very important to all
of us we work through our regions we
work through our country offices we work
with the national ministries of health
and across different sectors to ensure
that these systems continue that these
surveillance systems and that that the
medications are in countries that need
to be in-country so not sure if you want
to supplement I just like to add the
importance of vector control and how we
are actually focusing also and
encouraging the personal surrounding
vector control that can be done easily
without with with social distancing to
continue so in our guidance we've also
issued that the the norm of the vector
control to particularly deal with the
80s mosquito which a lot of the time is
around the house in in little flower
pots etc should be should be continued
and should be encouraged thank you and
maybe I can just add on this that well
they eat chicken goo yeah and cope with
19 are very different diseases and have
different pathways for which they're
caused they're very much diffused in one
way and that is that they can attack
vulnerable communities they're very
specific to context to the context of
water sanitation or work route
in poverty the lack of appropriate
management of wastewater lack of access
to healthcare for what can be
life-saving interventions there are so
many similarities when a new or an old
disease emerges in a community that is
not well served by health care but as
underlying issues both social and health
care issues these diseases exploit all
of those as the Director General has
said many times the cracks that exist in
our societies in terms of social justice
in terms of access to health care thing
is a very very good example of that and
and I think while they may not be very
similar diseases they exploit very
similar weaknesses in our societies and
in our health systems and if we work
towards universal health coverage if we
work towards strengthening core health
systems if we work as you're working so
well on integrated approaches and
primary health care delivered close and
within communities for multiple diseases
both in prevention and control and we
you
you
you
you
hello good afternoon and welcome to the
daily Downing Street press briefing I'd
like to start with a daily update on the
latest data on coronavirus you'll see
slides coming up now so the first slide
shows cases confirmed with a test so
seven million one hundred twenty one
thousand nine hundred and seventy six
Tests the corona virus have now been
carried out or posted out in the UK and
that includes one hundred and forty
thousand three hundred and fifty nine
tests carried out or posted yesterday
two hundred and ninety nine thousand two
hundred and fifty-one people have tested
positive and that is an increase of 1115
cases since yesterday may we have the
second slide please
so the second slide shows the latest
data from hospitals so three hundred and
eighty seven people were admitted to
hospital with corona virus in England
Wales and Northern Ireland on the 14th
of June that is down from around four
hundred and thirty five a week earlier
and down from a peak of 3432 on the 1st
of April 379 coronavirus patients are
currently in mechanical ventilation beds
in the United Kingdom and that is down
from 490 for a week ago and that in turn
is down from a peak of 3301 on the 12th
of April and May we have the third slide
please so as you'll see from the third
slide this shows what's happening in
hospitals across the country there are
now five thousand three hundred and
eight people in hospital with corona
virus in the UK that is down thirteen
percent from six thousand one hundred
and twenty-three a week ago and again in
turn that is down from a peak of twenty
thousand six hundred and ninety eight on
the 12th of April and as you'll see from
the graphs while there is some variation
most nations
regions in the UK are broadly following
a similar pattern now the fourth and
final slide we may have that please that
shows the daily figures for those who
have sadly lost their lives after
testing positive for coronavirus across
all settings the total number of deaths
now stands at 42 thousand 153 that sadly
an increase of 184 fatalities since
yesterday
now when you measure that on a 7-day
rolling average the daily number of
deaths now stands at 146 so that is down
from a peak of 943 on the 14th of April
so as you'll see from all of those four
slides we are making important progress
and today actually marks another
important milestone in just under one
hours time the best league in the world
will be back up and running after a
hundred day pause all but five countries
will be airing tonight's games
underlining football's global reach and
the soft power of UK sport the Premier
League is returning and the world will
be watching and of course it will be a
very different event to what we're used
to but there's no doubt that this is a
hugely symbolic moment an important step
forward in our careful journey back
towards normality players back in their
place of work and a boost for our
football loving nation and we've worked
really hard with football authorities
police and medical experts to get to
this point but we do need fans to play
their part too so please look after your
fellow fans and your communities by
watching from home to keep the home
advantage support from home now all 92
remaining Premier League's will be shown
playing Premier League games we've shown
live on TV and I'm delighted that I and
others managed to work hard to get a
third of them on free-to-air channels
Friday will be the first to free-to-air
with Norwich V Southampton then an
important day on Saturday
that will be when we've had the first
ever Premier League game on the BBC
followed by the Merseyside derby again
free to air on Sunday and there'll be
extended highlights of all the games
free to air so you won't have to miss a
single goal our sports men and women
have set some incredible examples during
this pandemic using their profiles to
support worthwhile causes across the
United Kingdom
England's men and women cricket teams
have donated half a million pounds
towards charitable causes
rugby league's Cheshire Bank West Bank
bears have delivered food and parcels to
the elderly and of course the England
and Manchester United Football and
Marcus Radford has made the front and
the back pages for the very best of
reasons highlighting the struggles
facing many families during this
difficult time but that is of course
[Music]
what happened in the last two weeks
absolutely has motivated me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]